kind of the main event for this evening
a candy draft
uh we go up a three-round candy draft uh
i i randomized the order up at the top
of the board
uh to make our picks theo would be first
and uh select a candy and put it on the
board if i don't get them good and
plenty so i'm about to piss on y'all
don't you got any boston baked beans
someone in the first three picks take
those good and bloodies you can't be
giving away your picks like that it's a
giraffe
we're in the war room right now i don't
know how what are we i don't know how it
works
like like a like nfl draft theo's gonna
be first pick
he'll go up out of all those candies he
gets to pick what's available go up now
yeah
i get the fourth pick in the first round
it was a randomized draft order before
the uh
randomized draft dude it's just like
you know damn well if you made theo
fourth pick in the first round we would
hit chad for the show
we come back tomorrow nick as a black
guy
looks like no i don't know what you're
talking about logos you guys mind doing
a quick read for me real quick
oh look at that gang homie yeah hell
yeah y'all
gay hell yeah halloween yeah brother
i'm going hard in the [ __ ] damn that
that caboose still out the back dog
talking about that horse saddle up
partner i put them ratchets number one
baby
if you want to add a uh thumbtack uh
because it'll probably come back get
them ratchets
hey so we pick and then we eat them uh
at the end yeah you get
you get your draft that's right
wait it's me audio come on baby
come on dog cat you're outside we'll see
the teams at the end
uh each person will have three three
items god how about chin's picture
i know well how about mom picture look
at those glasses
we took that last week doug i know the
chin's should have been masturbating
yesterday either
nothing to do with candy but you're up
chin yeah what are you jacking off in
candy what are they going to do
what do you want me to do man i was
jacking off both sins both sins for you
i couldn't handle myself oh here comes
bobby lee says
nobody ever here comes a six
seven bobby yeah they're
unbelievable bobby tree over here ain't
nobody buying that dog
that's a lazy costume chin that is a
lazy
costume dog what are you talking about
no you look like a librarian at a
[ __ ] motorcycle outlet
i can't believe snickers went all the
way to three either oh
yeah first of all yeah chin bad outfit
bad pit
no i think it's a great pick i would
number one overall coming really it's
like picking greg jennings right now
this is tough for me because i love
these are my favorite candy
i love milk duds bro pick one
you're that lame kid who gets back and
he's like well okay let me count them
all
out one jolly rancher you guys like to
trade candy
huh at the end yeah then i'm saying once
when you got all your bags you
shuffle them all out you trade and start
wheeling and dealing
dude and then we used to get the
suppositories too dude
oh chappelle you're up oh yeah there's a
hammer
i can't even see dude i used to get i i
used to get uh
yeah i think i'm good okay yeah
hell man he's got some scary huh yeah
where'd you find a hammer
it's on the ground i don't have a hammer
i think it's from chappelle's outfit
oreo is that yours no that's true i
don't have no hammer
since it's halloween you need a luigi
board oh yeah that's a great
and i get the wrap around so i get two
picks in a row okay
all right fine another podcast network
guys
damn get your dick out of our place dude
hey would a few squats kill you every
now and then
you need to get with theo's train or not
you got that mr burns ass
he's got that math doing ass somebody
got that math doing ass
bruh look like you take a [ __ ] laying
down nick
like two sheets to loose loose leaf
paperbacks
nick got two sheets of loose leaf paper
you better call it theo's trainer asap
son
a-s-s app bro you want half a cheek duck
oh you got those suckers i love those
caramel apple suckers
you can get those at the bank dude yeah
the analytics steve said it was a great
pick
[Laughter]
i nick got a dick on him y'all that
green suit proves it man
what are you talking about i do all
right
why are you looking at somebody's dick
that's not your own how can you avoid it
man he's in a [ __ ]
green spandex bro he comes out and puts
the candy in my face he does
you ate that horse's wiener you about
look took him on nick's wing
dude you don't want your a new podcast
networking not have a dick on you
he got that mantena bro
[Laughter]
that's the thing i worry about with
chappelle dude
chappelle's so white bro you worry about
the size of his penis
dude i've thought about it a lot i'm
glad you said that
bro you listening to my slip knot
as it starts to shrink you're up brendan
damn chappelle just picks the obvious
candy doug wait what do you mean what
happens eminem's and reese's i mean
obviously you sold those to support some
basketball teams
we're hey mister me and my friends are
saving up to go on the back
cruise can you help us raise some money
sir
good brother you like back chappelle huh
i like beck he will yeah vex great
i sat next to uh i sat across i almost
lied uh
from back on an airplane once oh did you
say anything uh i did
get a phone number of someone who worked
in his band a woman
oh and i never called her though oh but
i should have
you should have but she yeah it's over
now
how long ago was that this was probably
i'm not sure how long ago
it was at some point you guys know the
tape does work right yeah it seems
pretty strong but just in case
yeah what's that gummy worms
i got all the good ones cat looking fly
in that pick huh oh
thanks yeah i took that off her
instagram i took out the
the recipe oh you took the milk duds oh
you cut the breast out
you got it you're one of the sweater
puppies
that's my patreon you put the sweater
puppies back on for the patreon
[Laughter]
here
oh what is that there are just that
little pack of nerds dog the
original classic the classic yeah don't
let the sizes throw you off either if
it's a baby one we're just saying the
type of candy
like just because it's a baby mounds
don't be like oh i'm going to take the
baby mounds over the full-size stuff
we're seeing who has the best lineup
snickers theo you got the wrap around
you got one more pick oh yeah
the reach around dog that's all you
[ __ ] andy
honestly i like chin's line lineup so
far the best
you got snickers and gummy worms it's a
nice variety of chocolate
yep gummy chocolate's not too big the
gummies wait what's wrong with mine
what's the oh i love butterfinger like
you said it's a little classical
butterfinger
i think i like cats lineup and you went
peanut butter on both treats
oh peanut y'all slacking man well i'm
not a big sour
y'all a couple slacking i panicked
honestly you guys were talking about my
ass i
didn't just freak me out i wanted to get
out of the room
oh like two pages in a book
[Laughter]
that is the weakest costume dog it's
almost
it's all you know it's different it's
offensive it's a [ __ ] offensive
it's offensive that you would you got to
be
yeah you need a stain on your shirt you
need urine on you somewhere
yeah you need a couple of body fluids on
you a vintage worn out
sure that's stretched out a little too
much yeah you need a beautiful
girlfriend that's going to probably end
up with me if something ever happens to
him
brandon you're up you have no
i just expected more out of your chin
honestly i'm sorry
but just didn't you accept water from
cat
uh considering i didn't know what he
that he even dressed up yes
i told him we should have been jackie
chan and i should have been too young
oh no no no you should have done rush
hour would you get a black face
and you go chappelle could sign off on
it
oh no you got joe we should have done it
we're gonna do it but what happened we
didn't have enough outfits
i have you have no outfits i would do i
would do
uh can a black person do white face if
they want
um nick cannon and uh snoop dogg did i
don't know if it's okay or
still friendly jimmy kimmel did it yeah
are you a white chair oh yeah that's a
great movie yeah
here comes mr irrelevant
damn bro you and chin should have an ass
off
yeah dude and both of them already are
both need to hit a [ __ ] theo's
trainer man
that ass is absent dude all right so who
won
skittles i don't know how you decide
yeah how do you oh [ __ ] well we'll put
it out to the
people the chappelle's looking pretty
tasty though that's what i'm talking
about i love
mike chappelle's does look good
theo is definitely the worst no nicks is
l nation
is it yeah um
very uncomfortable
mine's a you have a specific palette
from mine you feel me yeah
yeah dude you have candy corn
in there that got voted worst candy in
the world
they're good when you post it on your
instagram
that candy is horrible what is it he
posted something oh yeah that one
it's like um i don't remember what kind
of it doesn't even have like a
little name on it it's just like wrapped
up the black or gray it's black or
orange
yeah it's black what is it what is real
story oh i love
like a laffy taffy a saltwater taffy
what are we talking about you'll see you
know exactly what we're talking about
yeah calm down
freaking taffy man like a
like a beach taffy like a cinnamon taste
like what
yeah oh those oh god that candy and
sometimes you got the
the freaking one on the bottom right
that was like the nougat
talk about that new watch yourself watch
your words
yeah brendan you got to chill dude no
it's a new game right no you you quit
saying it dude
yeah okay like thank you for having my
back
any time bro great [ __ ] pissing off
great boss anyways but yeah those
candies are disgusting yeah
[Music]